voici la planète mars différente de
celle que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
avec ses océans ces continents sa
végétation
un endroit où la vie du possible
énormes moyens technologiques seront
nécessaires pour remodeler la planète
rouge à l'image de la terre
pour que des nuages flottent dans une
atmosphère respirable
car tel est le défi transformer un
désert aride et glacial en un monde où
l'eau coule et l'herbe pousse
et
et ce qui est plus important encore
établir la vie sur mars mettrait fin au
doute et pour la première fois
l'homme ne se poserait pas la question
de savoir si les seuls dans l'univers
aujourd'hui voici le seul endroit où
nous savons que la vie existe
pourtant quand le vaisseau spatial
galileo a survolé la terre il n'a
détecté qu'un seul indice une grande
quantité d'oxygène
galileo a vu notre planète et son
satellite la lune mais ni animaux ni
plante
dotés d'équipements plus performants
galileo aurait vu les lumières des
villes
comme sur la côte ouest des états unis
ou en floride les lumières de la ville
depuis la terre nous admirons d'autres
lumières les étoiles et les galaxies du
cosmos
notre propre galaxie la voie lactée
abrite 10 milliards des toiles et des
millions d'entre elles sont aussi
ordinaire que le soleil notre étoile
il n'y a aucune certitude mais il est
vraisemblable que beaucoup de ces
étoiles possède des planètes où la vie a
pu se développer comme sur la terre et
si cette forme de vie est intelligente
nous devrions l'entendre
c'est ce qui motive les radioastronomes
à l'aide d'immenses télescope
ils guettent les ondes en provenance de
l'espace
hélas les années passent sans qu'il
capte le moindre sou
les radiotélescopes sont pourtant le
seul espoir de capter un jour un message
ils ont déjà apporté aux astronomes la
preuve que des espèces chimiques existe
quelque part dans l'univers des nuages
de gaz et de poussières qui flotte dans
notre galaxie contiennent des molécules
semblables à celles qui ont créé la vie
sur terre et engendrer l'espèce humaine
on
parmi les 200 milliards des toiles de la
voie lactée la terre n'est qu'une petite
planète qui tourne autour d'une étoile
banal dans la banlieue de notre galaxie
il doit y avoir une vie ailleurs
c'est dans la nature même de l'homme
d'explorer le monde qui l'entourent
continent après continent nous avons
colonisé notre planète
maintenant nous construisons des
stations spatiales des ponts vers les
autres planètes
il
tôt ou tard nous les atteindrons et nous
développerons peut-être une technologie
qui nous permettra de voyager plus loin
sur des années lumière vers d'autres
étoiles
mais aujourd'hui nous cherchons des
manifestations de la vie avec des moyens
plus modestes les instruments de
l'astronomie
une observation depuis l'orbité de la
terre a suscité un grand intérêt
les scientifiques cherchent et les
étoiles très jeune encore entourée d'une
enveloppe de matières des halos nous
pourrait jaillir des planètes
ici dans un grand nuage de gaz et de
poussière à 1300 années lumière de la
terre
le télescope spatial hubble a fait une
découverte remarquable
en fouillant dans la nébuleuse d'orion
voilà l'image vue par hubble d'une
étoile voilée d'un épais cocon de
poussière
est-ce ainsi que s'est formé notre
système solaire
cette étoile brillera tel un jour dans
l'espace après que des planètes swan et
du disque de poussières dans des
milliards d'années la vie apparaîtra
peut-être sur l'une de ces planètes des
êtres intelligents contempleront
l'espace et peut être eux aussi se
demande s'ils sont seuls dans l'univers
et une étoile entouré de planète n'est
pas obligatoirement une source de vie
prenons notre système solaire par
exemple près du soleil mercure brûlé et
aride toute vie y est impossible et à
l'autre extrême pluton la planète la
plus éloignée du soleil il y fait trop
froid et sombre pour que la vie se
développe
de même que sur les planètes gazeuses
géantes comme neptune
ou ure anus ou encore saturn
d autres planètes sont de meilleure
candidate comme vénus la jumelle de la
terre
ou mars notre voisine plus petit mais
nous le savons aujourd'hui la ville est
apparu que sur la terre pourquoi
revenons aux origines du système solaire
il y a quatre milliards et demi d'années
le soleil a commencé à briller et les
planètes naquirent du disque qui
l'entourent
la terre alors encore une enfant était
un petit monde compact comme vénus et
mars
composée des éléments les plus lourds du
disque protoplanétaire
mais elle était très différente de la
terre que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
c'était une boule liquide débordante de
chaleur et d'énergie est entouré d'une
fine croûte parsemé de volcans
la première atmosphère était composé de
gaz très nocif en s'élevant ils se sont
refroidies et se sont condensées en
nuages la pluie en tombant créa les
premiers océans
il peut ainsi pendant des millions
d'années
les océans recouvrent et
vraisemblablement des quatre cinquièmes
de la planète
la terre avait profondément changé mais
la vie n'était toujours pas apparu c'est
la pluie qui laporta pendant des siècles
des molécules organiques rue solaire du
ciel orageux les océans de varen
chaudron de matières organiques
puis il y a environ trois milliards et
demi d'années probablement dans des eaux
chaudes peu profondes des molécules
commencé à se multiplier
elle absorbe r d éléments nutritifs et
utilisèrent l'énergie du soleil c'était
le début de la vie sur la terre
quand les volcans se furent calmer
l'atmosphère s'apaisa échangera les
plantes libéré de plus en plus d'oxygène
quand les premiers animaux remp r hors
de l'eau l'air et est devenu respirable
notre planète et est devenu tranquille
et merveilleuse
aujourd'hui par la photosynthèse les
plantes continue à transformer l'énergie
du soleil en nourriture et à fournir
l'oxygène qui rend notre atmosphère
respirable
le monde et débordant de vie
mais qu'est-ce qui l'a déclenché et
quels mécanismes engendra la vie sur
terre
de plus en plus de scientifiques pensent
que la vie est peut être apparue sur la
terre grâce aux comètes qui ont apporté
des molécules organiques
c'est possible mais alors pourquoi pas
sur vénus autant de comètes ils sont
tombés que sur la terre et pourtant
venus est un monde stérile
et pourquoi pas sur mars
après la terre mars est le meilleur
candidat à la vie nous savons qu'il fut
un temps où il y avait de l'eau sur mars
les calottes polaires le prouve
et les monts volcanique témoignent d'un
passé mouvementé voici olympus mons avec
plus de 24 kilomètres de haut
c'est la plus haute montagne du système
solaire
les volcans martiens sont éteints depuis
longtemps mais dans le passé ils ont
créé une atmosphère semblable à celle de
la terre jeunes 6 mars un passé
géologique semblables pourquoi pas une
biologie parallèle
voici nos propres volcan sur l'archipel
des galapagos déshabillés de leurs
enveloppes naturel par ordinateur il
ressemble à s'y méprendre à la surface
de mars
alors pourquoi est ce que les îles
galapagos déborde de vie alors que la
surface de mars n'est qu'un désert aride
nous survolons la vallée marine heures
une fissure dans la taille comparable à
la distance entre la côte est et la côte
ouest des états unis 6 mars et des
océans
ce serait un immense fleuve
les calottes glaciaires de mars
rétrécissent et grossistes avec les
saisons
la glace est formé en partie de gaz
carbonique gelé mais il y à aussi de
l'eau ce qui confirme la théorie selon
laquelle jadis l'eau coulait sur mars
mais si c'est le cas qu'est ce qui s'est
passé
des photos prises par des sondes
spatiales apporte d'autres preuves de la
présence d'eau dans le passé ici un
réseau de canaux
et une larme façonné par des coulées
d'eau
mais comment est-ce que mars est devenu
un désert rouge y parle oxydes de fer
une réponse possible est la faible
gravité en surface la planète est à
moitié plus petite que la terre mars ne
pouvait pas empêcher son atmosphère de
s'évaporer dans l'espace ce qui n'était
pas un problème tant que les gaz
volcaniques compenser les pertes
mais la fin des éruptions marqua le
début des problèmes
la couche protectrice de vapeur d'eau et
de gaz carbonique qui capturait la
chaleur du soleil disparu mars berdy sa
chaleur et son nom
inéluctablement l'homme ira sur mars
et nous construirons des bases
permanentes sur mars après tout le
voyage depuis la terre ne durera qu'un
an
nous aurons besoin d'abris hermétique
l'atmosphère légère du gaz carbonique
est irrespirable
les explorateurs devront porter des
combinaisons pressurisés et ils
conduiront des véhicules d'exploration
ils devront chercher de l'eau qu'on
pense que des réservoirs de glace gisent
sous la surface et ils découvriront
peut-être des reliques d'une vie passée
des fossiles peut être nous des microbes
survivants dans la poussière
le grand rêve se réalisera beaucoup plus
tard faire de mars une nouvelle terre
pour transformer mars il faudra
construire des générateurs qui
produiront de grandes quantités de gaz
carbonique
quand l'atmosphère haut-rhin et des si
et ce sera réchauffer l'eau coulera
les calottes glaciaires fondre et les
océans se formeront ce sera la génèse de
mars
partout des plantes spécialement
acclimater fournira de l'oxygène et peu
à peu l'atmosphère deviendra respirable
mars ressemblera à la terre ce
bouleversement prendre à des milliards
d'années et aujourd'hui ce n'est encore
que de la science fiction
mais imaginez une croisière dans la
vallée marine heures
nos descendants contempleront dans l'eau
les reflets de martiens les reflets de
même
venus l'autre voisine de la terre la vie
s'y attellent jamais développé par sa
taille et sa densité
c'est la jumelle de la terre
en permanence entouré de nuages venus
est resté longtemps mystérieuse
ce n'est que récemment grâce aux sondes
spatiales équipés de radars que nous
avons pu entrevoir sa surface et
découvrir leur rib la vérité
venus souffre d'un effet de serre poussé
au paroxysme la chaleur du soleil est
retenue prisonnière par son atmosphère
composée à 96% de gaz carbonique
venus est un enfer voici les seules
photos réelles de la surface de la
planète
elle fut retransmise par radio avant que
la sonde ne fondent
la roche et du basalte probablement des
plaques de lave
des radars ont permis de tracer une
carte plus précise
leurs faisceaux ont percé les nuages
pour prendre ses premières images du sol
de vénus et des volcans apparurent
pourtant la planète et est plus plate
que prévu il y a moins le cratère et
moins de relief que sur mars ou sur la
terre la surface ressemble au fond d'un
océan lycée par les courants
les radars révélèrent d'autres
merveilles une fois percer la couche de
nuages on pouvait survolé la surface de
vénus
voici la topographie de vénus recréé par
un ordinateur utilisant les données des
radars
les auteurs sont exagérées et les
couleurs le produit de l'imagination des
hommes mais en dehors de ça les détails
sont correctes
des cratères témoignent de l'impact de
météorites
ces structures sont le résultat
d'éruption volcanique plaqué au sol par
l'atmosphère pesante la pression ici et
90 fois plus forte que sur la terre
un volcan haut d'un kilomètre et demi
probablement est un parmi toutes les
planètes c'est vénus qui a le plus de
volcans
c'est aussi un enfer des températures de
4 180 degrés celsius une visibilité
troubles et des vents et des orages et
quand il pleut c'est une pluie d'acide
sulfurique
nous avons beaucoup de choses à
apprendre sur vénus pourquoi est-ce que
sa rotation se fait dans le sens inverse
de celle de mars et de la terre pourquoi
est-ce un enfer la vie n'est jamais
apparu sur vénus et n'y apparaîtra
probablement jamais
une son pénètre les nuages d'un autre
monde jupiter
le colosse de gaz la quête d'une autre
vie continue
après la stérilité de vénus et de mars
jupiter et le prochain candidat
bien que jupiter sont à presque un demi
milliard de km du soleil
ce n'est pas une boule de gaz gelé comme
le montrent ces images infrarouges
il y à des zones d'émission de chaleur
jupiter et mais plus d'énergie qu'elle
n'en reçoit
mais les sommets de ces nuages sont
froids moins 130 degrés et ils sont
chargés de gaz toxiques comme l'ammoniac
et le méthane
c'est un endroit hostile pourtant en
dessous des nuages
les températures s'élèvent on sait que
des molécules organiques complexes sont
présentes dans cette atmosphère
certains scientifiques pensent que les
conditions qui règnent sur cette planète
aujourd'hui ressemble à celle de la
terre quand la vie s'y est développée la
vie va-t-elle apparaître sur cette
planète des microorganismes sont ils
présents sur jupiter
europe l'un des seize satellites en
orbite autour de jupiter est l'un des
incubateurs possible
sous une masse croûte de glace s'étend
peut-être un océan trouble et
d'éruptions volcaniques
comme dans nos propres océans des
créatures s'accroche peut-être aux
parois les volcans se nourrissant
d'éléments chimiques et se développant
dans l'obscurité
encore plus loin du soleil nous allons
également sondé cette boule lice
enveloppé de brouillard et de mystères
ses tics ans un satellite de saturne
aussi grand qu'une planète
les scientifiques pensent que sous son
brouillard titan offre les conditions
chimiques nécessaires à la vie une neige
d'hydrocarbures et des lacs de méthane
c'est la terre dans un congélateur
mais il pense qu'un jour titan
s'éveillera à la vie dans cinq milliards
d'années
titan succombera le soleil commencera à
agoniser et deviendra une étoile géante
rouge qui fera bouillir les océans de la
terre
mais la vie se développera peut-être ici
et et qui sait
titan pourrait devenir un canot de
sauvetage pour l'humanité
la terre ne sera plus alors qu'un désert
de cendres
à court terme cette quête de la vie est
vaine
pourtant il se pourrait que des
organismes très simple se cachent sur le
satellite en europe où sur la planète
mars
mais au delà du système solaire dans la
famille des toiles que nous appelons
notre galaxie n'avons détecté aucun
signe de vie intelligente
jour et nuit ou scrutons l'espace dans
la tente d'un appel un message qui nous
dirait que nous ne sommes pas seuls
dans des centaines peut être des
milliards d'années nous rencontrerons
peut-être d être venues d'autres mondes
en attendant ce jour l'homme est seul
pour peupler les planètes et voyager
vers les étoiles